vous êtes déjà fait mordre par un chien
non par un chat oui pas manque mais je
me suis fait agresser comme ça par
derrière vous derrière c'est sûr que
c'est un chat ou chien il avait des
grosses griffes
oui mais ça a même traversé mon jean
jean
j'étais dans un cabinet de vétérinaire
avec mon chien de l'époque on adore et
en fait il y avait un chat parce qu'il
reconnaît tous les chats errants et
celui ci n'est pas très habitués à être
avec d'autres animaux et compris des
chiens donc il m'a vu avec le chien qui
était un gros labrador il était en haut
d'une armoire et s'est jeté sur moi
comme ça mais ça que les plus beaux
fesses et s'agripper l'appui après il
est descendu la et franchement il m'a il
a traversé le jeans je saignais c'était
sa première rencontre avec patauge
[Applaudissements]
il a attaqué le culte blade le
cheminement du chèque au départ et 107 à
quel chien puis l'a vu ces faits s'ils
étaient des mortiers ont finalement
c'est peut-être plus dangereux